en france depuis le début de son procès
patrick dils affirme qu'il a avoué le
double meurtre de montigny-lès-metz sous
la pression policière il était confronté
pour la première fois aujourd'hui à ses
enquêteurs et les méthodes de
l'inspecteur varley qui a mené le
dossier ont été remises en cause a lyon
clément weill-raynal sa maghrabi quinze
ans après l'inspecteur bernard varlet
aujourd'hui à la retraite est toujours
fier de son enquête probablement la plus
belle de sa carrière
c'est lui qui avait eu l'intuition de la
culpabilité de patrick dils
c'est lui qui avait interpellé le jeune
homme et c'est lui qui avait recueilli
ses aveux ni plus que jamais à la
culpabilité de la pratique bilan
j'ai pas changer ça sur deux appareils
ce sont ces aveux qui sont aujourd'hui
contestée sur les bancs de la défense
rompu aux techniques de la garde à vue
l'inspecteur varlet son équipe avait su
mettre patrick dils en confiance sans
brutalité ni pression ils avaient
longuement parlé aux jeunes garçons
nous avons réussi à ce qu'ils se
confient spontanément raconte
aujourd'hui l'inspecteur varlet il nous
a livré des éléments que nous ignorions
et que seul le véritable meurtrier
pouvait connaître patrick dils lui
affirme le contraire
j'ai été manipulé je suis satisfait que
de façon très claire il était démontré
ce matin que les aveux de patrick dils
ne sont pas des aveux
sans moyens de défense il a rien pour se
défendre
donc il à la seule chose qui peut faire
pour se défendre c'est à dire qu'on le
lui a suggéré des réponses pour faire
tomber les aveux ils savent eux sont là
ils existent ont été réitérées devant un
de mes collègues qui ont été réitérées
plusieurs reprises orange juge
d'instruction réitéré devant les
psychologues et les psychiatres réitéré
le jour de la reconstitution quatrième
jour d'audiences et l'on en revient
toujours à la question centrale des
aveux pourquoi le jeune homme at il
avoué avec un tel luxe de précisions
cette question pèsera lourd dans la
balance à l'heure du verdict